bon alors kad et olivier oui à la douce
à bras le corps
comment ça va on s'engage vis comme g
ouais et d'aimer votre femme
après ces ruptures parce que la vie
c'est bourré et le rugby c'est pas des
[ __ ] je me pose quelques jours chesnais
et le match race a pu presque jours ce
n'est que c'est les couples et notamment
les couples du monde disent oui il faut
en général de communal et femmes mais
comme il est comique
est-ce que ça arrive que par exemple une
à une qui drague olivier et qui
repartent avec cadeaux en version mais
ça tout le temps ça va arriver ce soir
non c'est qu'il est toujours en rade a
finalement qu'est ce qui reste
je suis guéri lunettes non mais je vais
t'aider à une dame avis c'est pas ça
donc 17 mariage 83 divorcer
j'ai fait l'amour tous les jours voilà
mariage ici lâche maintenant c'est
pourquoi c'est un bon avant j'étais
avant les comiques
oui ça j'essaie est prêt à venir à moi
et mes loyers non mais avant bon alors
c'est en soit fini avant j'étais commis
c'est vrai que le fait de faire rien et
de mettre tout ça en avant ça permet de
se défendre de quelque chose alors je
sais pas je cracherais système c'est
trash masse génère l abattre
je serais déjà mort laisse moi finir je
vous laisse passer le système
je veux dire que la colonie systématique
comme ça c'est ce qu'il est en train de
faire la passe est pour quelque chose
évidemment c'est bien je sais quoi on va
pas aller au fond du cqn on arrive à
faire ça c'est rien du tout je m'en fous
complètement alors ce qu'on se rend au
brusc aller au lit il arrête
voilà on y est allés boire une bière
merci et m'ont redonné pour le jeu de la
vérité dans tout allait bien parce que
là je sens que ça va être chaud alors
ils vont boire leur bière d'or et
c'était prévu je leur ai dit radiation a
bien chauffé la salle albert mais on
vient de bien sûr bien sûr qu'ils
reviennent bien su le faire légalement